durch unsere arbeit treffen wir immer
wieder menschen die sehr nervös sind
deutsch zu sprechen
manche menschen haben sogar richtig
angst deutsch zu sprechen und ich kann
das gut verstehen wenn du eine
fremdsprache sprichst dann bist du nicht
die gleiche person wie in deiner
muttersprache
ein freund von mir hat mal gesagt dass
er sich plötzlich wieder fühlt wie ein
kind wenn er deutsch spricht und ich
denke das stimmt auch ein bisschen wenn
du eine fremdsprache sprichst dann bist
du plötzlich nicht so witzig nicht so
spontan und auch manchmal nicht so
kompetent wie du dich in deiner
muttersprache ausdrücken
ich kenne dieses gefühl sehr gut denn
wenn ich niederländisch oder polnisch
sprechen dann fühle ich mich ganz
genauso und heute möchte ich mit euch
über drei tipps oder drei ideen sprechen
die mir geholfen haben diese ängste zu
überwinden
zunächst einmal ist es wichtig
festzustellen ob man vielleicht eine
generelle angst hat zu sprechen
denn wenn wir diese ängste kennen und
diese schwächen kennen dann ist es
vielleicht auch einfach hat diese zu
akzeptieren und diese zu überwinden wenn
ich zum beispiel mit meinen freunden
sprechen dann fühle ich mich sehr gut
und selbstbewusst ich habe keine angst
zu sprechen
aber wenn ich zum beispiel irgendwo
anrufen muss oder vor meiner klasse
stehe oder plötzlich auf einer bühne vor
vielen leuten stehe dann habe ich
plötzlich sehr viel angst zu sprechen
und wenn ich diese angst in meiner
muttersprache schon habe dann ist sich
vermutlich in einer fremdsprache sehr
viel stärker ausgeprägt und dessen muss
ich mir einfach bewusst sein
ich persönlich hatte alle von diesen
genannten ängsten und es hat mich sehr
lange gekostet diese ängste auch zu
überwinden
am ende hat es mir aber geholfen mich
immer wieder diese herausforderung zu
stellen und dadurch bin ich auch nun in
anderen situationen viel selbstbewusster
zum beispiel wenn ich eine neue sprache
spreche der zweite tipp ist
finde einen weg um immer wieder deine
grenzen zu testen
viele deutschlerner finden es schwierig
diese erste hürde zu meistern um flüssig
sätze zu bilden
du hast vielleicht schon a2 oder b1
niveau erreicht das heißt du kannst
schon ziemlich viele vokabeln und du
kennst die basis der deutschen grammatik
aber du kannst noch keine flüssigen
setzte in einem gespräch bilden in
deutschland denke ich habt ihr es dabei
besonders schwierig denn viele menschen
wechseln direkt ins englische wenn sie
sehen dass du ein problem hast einen
flüssigen satz zu bilden
im polnischen zum beispiel wenn ich bei
euch lerne habe ich dieses problem nicht
so sehr wenn ich zum beispiel in polen
etwas bestelle dann läuft das gespräch
oft so ab ich bestelle etwas auf
polnisch die kellnerin fragt mich etwas
auf polnisch ich sage dass ich den satz
nicht verstehe
die kellnerin sagt noch mal etwas auf
polnisch und wenn ich es dann immer noch
nicht verstehen dann sage ich ihr dass
mein freund ich nicht so gut ist und
frage sie ob sie auch englisch sprechen
kann und dann finden wir irgendwie immer
zusammen und finden eine lösung
in deutschland läuft das ganz oft so ab
du fragst etwas auf deutsch
der kellner sieht dass du nicht
muttersprachlich deutsch sprichst
er will es dir einfacher machen und
wechselt sofort ins englische
für viele deutschlerner ist diese
erfahrung sehr frustrierend denn ihr
werdet immer wieder an genau dieser
gleichen stelle stecken und kommt
einfach nicht weiter in ein gespräch
was kann man also tun um immer wieder
seine grenzen zu testen
ich denke ihr könnt zwei sachen machen
erstens könnte ihr immer wieder eine
gesprächssituation herstellen in der ihr
einen schritt weiter geht
zum beispiel könnt ihr einen freund
bitten zweimal die woche mit euch 30
minuten deutsch zu sprechen ohne in eine
an
ihre sprache zu wechseln viele
multikulturelle paare haben zum beispiel
so eine regel dass sie immer zu
bestimmten zeiten eine sprache sprechen
und zu bestimmten zeiten eine andere
sprache und dadurch helfen sie sich
gegenseitig sich nicht in einer anderen
sprache zu unterbrechen
ein anderer tipp wäre bestimmte sätze
mit denen ihr manchmal schwierigkeiten
habt von vorneherein auswendig zu lernen
und daher kommt auch der dritte tipp
tipp 3 ist lerne ein paar standard sätze
auswendig lernen ein paar sätze die dir
in bestimmten situationen weiterhelfen
und lerne sie wirklich so flüssig dass
du sie im schlaf auswendig kannst das
hilft dir dabei in bestimmten
situationen einfach deine standardsätze
zu benutzen
dadurch hast du mehr selbstbewusstsein
und es hilft die auch in einer
gesprächssituation dich auf neue
vokabeln und neue ausdrücke zu
konzentrieren statt immer wieder an der
gleichen stelle und in den gleichen
setzen hängen zu bleiben
hier sind ein paar standardsätze oder
eröffnungs setzte die ihr auswendig
lernen könnt entschuldigung könnten sie
das noch einmal auf deutsch sagen ich
lerne gerade deutsch und es würde mir
sehr helfen wenn sie mir auf deutsch
antworten könnten oder informell
entschuldigung
kannst du das noch mal auf deutsch sagen
ich lerne gerade deutsch und es würde
mir sehr helfen wenn du mir auf deutsch
antworten könntest oder entschuldigung
ich habe diesen satz nicht verstanden
könnte sie noch mal wiederholen
ich lerne gerade deutsch und es würde
mir sehr helfen
du kannst aber auch andere sätze
auswendig lernen zum beispiel wenn man
im restaurant etwas bestellt ein
schnitzel eine pommes und ein bier bitte
dadurch ist die chance dass der kellner
auch auf deutsch antwortet deutlich
höher
du kannst natürlich auch viele andere
sätze auswendig lernt
zb antworten auf fragen die den menschen
häufig stellen diese sätze helfen dir
eine erste hürde zu überwinden und ein
gespräch zu beginnen
ich kann zum beispiel auch voll nicht
sagen tschüss carsten kommoß polak im
shop boys cool allem polski jetzt bat so
klingt schon fast ein bisschen fließend
aber tatsächlich kann ich gar nicht so
viel sagen
und das macht aber nichts ich kann mit
diesem paar sätzen eigentlich immer ein
kleines gespräch beginnen und das ist
immer ein bisschen witzig und polen und
das könnt ihr auch in deutsch machen
das war unser video für heute wir hoffen
es hat euch gefallen wenn es euch
gefallen habt gebt uns ein like und
jetzt warten wir auf eure kommentare
wir hoffen ihr beteiligt euch an der
diskussion diese woche denn wir wollen
von euch wissen welche tipps habt hier
um eure nervosität zu überwinden wenn
ihr eine fremde sprache spricht schreibt
uns unbedingt eine kommentar wenn ihr
sie german unterstützen möchte und
unsere arbeit unterstützen möchte dann
werdet ein patch und natürlich solltet
ihr unbedingt easy german abonnieren
bis bald schaltet auch nächste woche
wieder ein tschüss